so one way
to achieve layer one scaling is to
increase the block size
yes hence the block size wars quote
unquote
and uh you actually tweeted something
about uh
people are saying that vitality changed
his mind about the in
he he went from being a small
one from being big to small is it big to
small and
uh but you said i've been a medium
blocker all along so maybe you can also
comment on on where on the very basic
aspect before you even get the sharding
of where you stand on this block
size debate sure so the way that i think
about the trade-off is i think about it
as a trade-off between
making it easy to write to the
blockchain and making it easy to read
the blockchain
right so when i say read i just mean you
know have a node and actually verify it
and make sure that it's correct and all
of those things
and then by right i mean send
transactions so like
i think for decentralization it's it's
important for both of these tasks to be
accessible
and i think that they're like about
equally important right if you have a
chain that's too expensive to read then
everyone will just trust a few people to
like read for them and then those people
can change the rules without anyone
else's permission
but if on the other hand it becomes
really expensive to write
then everyone will move on to basically
second layer systems that are incredibly
centralized and like that takes away
from
you know decentralization and
self-sovereignty as well so
this has been my viewpoints like pretty
much the whole time right it's that like
you know you need this balance and going
in one direction or the other direction
is very unhealthy
in the bitcoin case um basically what
happens was that
bitcoin originally like at the very
beginning it didn't really have a block
size
it just had an accidental block size of
32 meg
or a block size limit of 32 megabytes
because that just happens to be the
limit of
the peer-to-peer messages um but that's
interesting i didn't even know that part
yeah but then um satoshi back in 2010
was worried that even 32 megabyte blocks
would be too hard to process so he
uh put the limit down to one megabyte
and you know i think
the i put you mean sneaked in there yeah
just like made an update to the bitcoin
software that made blocks bigger than
one i think it's a million bytes um
invalid and i think the impression that
most people had at the time is that you
know this is just
a temporary safety measure and over time
you know though as we become more
confident in the software that limit
would be
and like raised some uh somewhat
um but ba then
of when the actual usage of the
blockchain started going up
and then it started going up first to
100 kilobytes
per block then to 250 kilobytes per
block then to 500 kilobytes per block
let me know there started kind of coming
out of the woodworks this opinion that
like no that limit should just not be
increased
and and you know then there are all of
these attempts at compromising right
um you know first there's like a
proposal for 20 megabyte blocks then
there was the 248 proposal
which is um a bit ironic because the 248
proposal started off being
like a small block negotiating position
but then when the big black people came
back and said like hey where are we
aren't we going to do this they're like
oh no no no we don't want them we don't
want the block size increases anymore
uh so you know there were these two
different positions right the small
blockers
i think they valued one megabyte blocks
for two reasons
one is that they just like really really
believe in the importance of
being able to read the chain but two is
that a lot of them
really believe in in maintaining this
norm of never hard forking
right right so the difference between a
hard fork and a soft fork is basically
that
in a soft fork um blocks that were any
block that's valid under the new rules
was still valid under the old rules
so if you have a client that verifies
according to the old rules then you'll
still be able to accept the chain
that follows the new rules whereas with
a hard fork like you have to
update your code in order to stay on the
chain
and look they have this belief that
you know soft forks are kind of either
less coercive than hard forks which by
the way i completely disagree with
um i actually think soft forks are more
coercive because like basically they
force everyone who disagrees to sort of
go along by default
um but or they have this um
opinion that um there's like
it's more difficult to abuse soft forks
to do really mean things like or
that like completely violate people's
expectations like increasing the supply
which is like you know there i think
there is some truth to that
um so because of you know these reasons
they just say we're only going to do
soft forks and we're we don't we wants
to just not do any hard forks
and they eventually discovered this idea
called segregated witness that allows
for like a very tiny
block size increase to like the
equivalent of about two megabytes
um with a soft fork it's it's just a
really
like weird and devious trick like
basically what they do
is they take the signatures of
transactions and then they put them
outside of the block
and then they add an extra rule that
says that like every for a block to be
valid the blog has to come with a
separate
like basically extension block that
contains all of the transaction
signatures
right so you know when you measure it
according to the old rules like you know
hey it adds up to less than a million
but actually there's this extension
block that
the old protocol doesn't even know about
so it's a hack that that seemed to work
to
do in a small way extended exercise in
the box but so
you know small block side was like happy
with these very low levels of block size
and the big block side wanted to
expand to you know at the very least go
to four megabytes then you know maybe go
maybe eight to twenty there are there's
disagreements within there as well
um i definitely was favoring the big
side um
the whole way through as you can
probably tell
um but even though so the argument
against the big
is that uh it uh makes things more
centralized yes
because fewer people can run a note that
verifies the chain and also because any
of these things would require a hard
fork and
you know hard forks are inherently
rescued
you